Gina is whether some Billings Montana
hi Gina how are you I'm very well thank
you mr. an see your work is Mahdi in the
kingdom well thank you man how can I
help you bet my husband and I have been
retired for about 11 years we've always
lived very conservatively taking very
few vacations etc we have no debt our
house is paid for asset thank you fire
assets equal approximately 5 million
dollars where to go my thank you my
husband philosophy is that we exist to
take care of the fortune my philosophy
is that the fortune exists to take care
of us and never the twain shall meet
when we retired we determined a budget
which have not changed in 11 years
I recently approached him to ask for an
increase in our budget because we're
living fairly meanly he doesn't want to
increase our budget he calls it a
downward spiral because he wants the
entire principle left when we die I
wanted to hear your thoughts on this
mm-hmm so what is your annual budget I'm
sorry I don't know he does not let me
know anything about the money how long
have you been married 41 years you let
him get away with that a long time
haven't you it really is I'm terrible
with money grades of money so it's kind
of been a tacit agreement and a not so
tacit agreement here Torquay do you have
any idea what the household what your
income is off your investments you said
you got five million in assets how do
you know that I just went to the went to
enough meetings with a financial planner
to know that okay and the money is
invested primarily in what the five
million dollars it's what's it invested
in I'm sorry i I'm an idiot and I don't
know okay so you went to the meetings
but it's very conservatively I didn't
really understand it I don't know
anything about it it's there it's no
risk I can tell you that so what is it
your
wanting to do with money that he done
all day I am wanting to ease up the fun
so that trips can be planned work can be
done on the home if I wonder if we want
to go out to dinner to Nonna's battle
I'm not wanting anything extravagant
okay well I think the fortune does not
exist to serve you and I don't think you
exist to serve the fortune I think both
of those ideas are wrong I think the the
fortune exists that you manage it for
the glory of God there you go
and it exists for that now what what
does scripture tell us because you
mentioned God earlier in our
conversation so I'll go around and so
scripture tells us to take care of our
own householder we're worse than other
labor and where we're having a
disagreement here is what's taking care
of your own household you should have a
$200,000 your income and it sounds like
tightwad boys got you on about 50 grand
e here so I think you need to go on some
trips and I think you guys probably need
to sit down with a pastor a good
marriage counselor and you need to find
out what your income is and what the
budget is and the two of you need to be
making these decisions more together I'm
not asking you to start spending like
Congress but I think you need to be
enjoying some of this money more than
you are it's a good idea to talk about
our last call for a minute five million
dollars in assets in retirement I'd like
to go on a few trips and fix up the
house a little now
could she be understating that yeah she
could be she may be saying I want to
spend two hundred thousand dollars a
year on travel and five hundred thousand
fixing up our house if that's what she
meant and but I didn't think that and
she didn't want you and I to think that
the way she was presenting it so I'm
assuming and I did assume that the
expenses to do them a few minor repairs
to the house and maybe going a cruise or
finally take that trip to Paris that
they've always wanted to take was all
she was talking about and very very
doable on that asset base and the income
it should be creating see if you have
five million dollars invested in it
10% that's $500,000 a year without
touching the principle now what I
suggest you necessarily draw down that
much no but that's you know that that's
a pretty broad range from I can't afford
to repair my home so I don't know the
history in there 41 year marriage she
said he was good with money she's not so
she didn't know anything by the way I'll
tell you don't live your life that way
number one work on yourself enough that
you get competent enough and mature
enough with your spending that the two
of you can work together and you don't
have to be protected from yourself by
your spouse and spouses should not be
operating where one of them doesn't know
what's going on or is controlled by the
other one and that's how she feels now
possibly she was overstating all of that
I don't know but so here's the thing
from a scriptural standpoint for those
of us that are people of faith people of
the book here's what the book says take
care of your own household first or
you're worse than an unbeliever it also
says a good man leaves an inheritance to
his children's children
it also says God loves a cheerful Giver
so there's three things scripturally
that you should always be doing with
money and it is your purpose it is
managing God's money for his glory when
you do these three things properly you
enjoy money and provide for necessities
that's taking care of your own household
if you have five million dollars in
assets creating two to five hundred
thousand dollars of growth every year
and you refuse to take your wife on a
cruise that cost five thousand dollars
that is not taking care of your
household that
is wrong now if you're broke and you
have two hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt no you're not going on
a cruise you dumb-butt know that's not
what we're talking about but money has
three possible uses as you build it now
whether you're a person of faith or not
it has three possible uses number one
you have fun with it and that includes
taking care of basic necessities but
we're going to start with that I mean
you take care of your house you enjoy
some money you buy that classic car
you've always wanted you go on that trip
to Australia you've always wanted to do
or Africa or Paris I don't know what it
is you fix up the you build a barn out
back because you've always wanted to
raise a few a few head of cattle I don't
know what your dream is at retirement
but some enjoying the money consuming
some not all but some of the money is
proper it should be the smaller
percentage of these three the second
thing you do is you do continue to
invest it but you have no obligation
to leave it to the next generation 100%
intact now if you've got five million
and you can't live off of two to five
hundred thousand and there's probably
something wrong and you should be able
to leave that principle in place but
it's not the end of the world if you
don't if you left them 4 million instead
of 5 million so what it's not the end of
the world but leaving an inheritance to
your children's children is biblical and
inheritance and it's an inheritance of
character an inheritance of memories and
legacy and it's money is what that's
referring to in Scripture it's all of
those things it's not just oh it just
means it just means leave them character
no it doesn't means leave money Solomon
built the temple
that the people of God worshiped in and
he did not build it with his money he
built it with his dad's money David left
him the money for an inheritance it was
David's money that was left that's how
his bill was not sought Simon did not
acquire the wealth so something to
consider
biblical inheritance is a real thing and
it's not it's not you're not a sinner if
you don't do it but this idea that
somehow you're supposed to leave the
next generation broke because children
are going to be ruined by money now
children are just the fact that they
were ruined is revealed by money it is
not the money didn't ruin them they were
already bad the money just revealed it
and so your job is to raise kids that
can manage wealth because they can
manage life that's your job so you spend
some on you because you take care of
your own household you spend you leave
some as an inheritance a godly man
leaves an inheritance to his children's
children and you are outrageously
generous now I will tell you that most
spenders are generous and most tightwads
are not by nature by nature if you are a
saver giving is harder for you than it
is if you're a spender most of the time
not always but most of the time that's
the case that's not a bad thing my wife
is the saver and she is much more
deliberate and careful and cynical about
our generosity than I am
I'm sloppier I have a tendency to be I
have to work against it but have a
tendency to be sloppier in my generosity
and more outrageous in my generosity
than she does
but I'm the spender of the two of us by
Nature now again I've learned to control
that I'm a grown-up now I used to be a
child in a grown-up body and so I've
worked through that and that's why God
makes me teach this every day you're my
support group my name is Dave and I like
stuff so you enjoy spending some of it
you enjoy being outrageously generous
for some of it you leave an inheritance
to your children's children and that's
the investing side so you're always
giving you're always enjoying and
spending you're always investing all
your life and that's a proper view of
money and if you want to have a
high-quality marriage both of you need
to be trust worthy worthy of trust to
each other in other words one of you is
not a spending child princess that's out
of control
and has to be protected from yourself
and one of you can't be the ogre control
freak I'm the only one of the two of us
that has a brain I earned all the money
you have no rights well that's a that's
not a healthy relationship that's a
bunch of garbage
I earned the money it's my money
well then you shouldn't have been
married because your marriage vows says
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledged
the old marriage vows from the Book of
Common Prayer say that for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health and
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
that's the way you operate a properly
done marriage with a proper relationship
that is high quality this mental health
it's not toxic and and so if you have to
hide money from each other you have a
problem in your relationship if you have
to protect one of you from the other one
you have a problem in your relationship
not in your money one of you is not
worthy of trust you're not trustworthy
you gotta work on that stuff don't get
fifty years into a marriage and just be
discovering that it's just not worth it
then the money becomes curse rather than
a blessing